[Música]
hola soy ezequiel local
este
tengo
a veces está pasando la presentación
todo
bueno es así así ha sido mi vida
sorpresas todo el tiempo poner buena
cara
dificultades
ahora sí
bueno de vuelta hola soy ezequiel local
y tengo 49 años
nací en comodoro rivadavia por la
profesión de mi papá viví en siete
ciudades
fui a siete colegios
después parece que
me contagié mucho esa cuestión nómade y
trabajé en siete empresas
viví fuera del país
vivo en benavides desde hace 10 años en
tigre y bueno en mi familia tengo tres
hermanos
y todo lo que he ido viviendo durante el
transcurso de estos 49 maravillosos años
de vida hermosa y divertida y divertida
me lo enseñó papá papá me enseñó a
disfrutar de la vida a divertirme y mi
mamá me enseñó a no rendirme nunca
y mis hermanos me enseñan muchas cosas
pero bueno si tengo que empezar a
contarle todo lo que me ha enseñado
todas las personas con las que me he
cruzado imagínense de siete ciudades
siete empresas siete colegios
no termino no me alcanza el tiempo así
que después el deporte ha marcado
muchísimo a mi vida también yo empecé a
jugar al tenis a los 6 años y competía
viajaba jugado provinciales en ese
momento vivía en villa maría córdoba
de repente cuando me fui a vivir a pilar
descubrí que el rugby me encantaba no me
dejaban jugar al rugby en casa no quería
que jugar retirar una persona muy
miedosa y entonces yo me escapaba iba a
jugar revisen que ellos supieran así que
estuve jugando unos meses a escondidas
en el club atlético pilar y bueno hasta
que me descubrieron ya había un índice
que no podían decir que no después jugué
en el tiro federal de campana porque me
mudé a campana y cuando vine a buenos
aires a estudiar jugué dos años en
alumni y por cuestiones de la vida
conocí gente de hindú y ellos me
convencieron de ir a hindú hindúes el
club donde yo hoy siento que estoy en el
patio de mi casa
hindú yo dejé de jugar en hindú y
durante 20 años no pude volver al club
porque me daba angustia ver jugar a los
chicos y yo no poder jugar ahí
lo que hacía mientras tanto era me
anotaba en los torneos de rango y de
rango empresarial y lesione
interempresario que había organizado
equipos y despuntado servicio ahí y
después con algo que me pasa que ahora
les voy a contar ellos me ayudaron a
volver al club y cuando vio el club
parecía que me había ido el día anterior
y todo eso fue formando mi familia qué
se fue creciendo el 9 de diciembre del
nace justina el 23 de enero del 2011 del
2009 nace zeferino y el 27 de junio del
2011 nace cipriano y mi familia mi
familia no es solamente el hermano el
primo familia es donde hay amor alguien
me enseñó que familia donde hay amor
entonces realmente yo de una familia
numerosa tremenda por toda la historia
de vida que tengo y que fui aprendiendo
de ellos y fui aprendiendo tantas cosas
de hecho hoy los chicos los chicos de
indugel m8 me enseñan tantas cosas
cuando los entreno y una de las cosas
que
que aprendí en la vida es que hay dos
perros que están peleando siempre cada
uno de nosotros tenemos dos perros
dentro que pelean siempre uno es el
perro de la tristeza del dolor del miedo
de la angustia y otro es el perro de la
alegría del amor de la sre de la
valentía y quién gana quién gana de los
dos perros y gana el que esté más fuerte
y cómo hacemos que el perro esté más
fuerte y le damos de comer cómo le damos
de comer
cómo le damos de comer al perro que
queremos que gane quién quiere de dónde
la mano quién quiere que en el perro de
la alegría del amor del hacer de la
valentía y si todo se levanta una mano
ahora quien no se ha enojado alguna vez
que no ha discutido en la calle porque
le encerraron con el auto o quien no se
ha peleado por un partido de fútbol
y quien no ha estado triste quien no ha
llorado que no ha tenido dolor angustia
fracaso miedo todos es difícil esos
perros están en batalla continua dentro
nuestro y uno de los secretos es saber
cómo darle de comer al perro que
queremos que gane y bueno la vida me ha
enseñado a darle de comer al perro que
quiero que gane no gano siempre
lamentablemente pero pero va ganando va
ganando cada vez más y yo disfruto de la
vida soy una persona que me llevan todo
buen humor
qué gran parte del tiempo esté de buen
humor obviamente que me enojo y cuando
me enojo realmente no me aguanto ni yo
me he peleado en la calle por temas de
tránsito pero cuando cuando pasa algo
ello devuelve una sonrisa o pido
disculpas o cambia y esos son detalles
que podemos ir logrando cada uno de
nosotros porque nosotros podemos ser el
protagonista del cambio en nuestra vida
vos querés cambiar el mundo
imagínatelo como crees que sea y hacelo
en el detalle más simple entrando un
ascensor todos con cara de culo o con
cara de estar en otro lado y vos decir
buenos días buenas tardes con que uno se
sonría logras te un detalle que no sabes
qué puede pasar con eso porque esa
persona sale del ascensor y de repente
tenía una reunión y fue sonriendo en
medio con carga con lo logras te que
vaya sonriendo desde esos detalles hasta
otros por ahí un poco más banales que no
ha pasado por un bache y lo esquivado y
cuando pasa muchas veces que está así
cuando pasa muchas veces levantas el
teléfono del municipio que corresponde
decir si hay un bache y cuándo
y bueno por ahí logramos un pequeño
cambio que agarre desde ese bache
y quien no ha arreglado o que no ha
cambiado una rueda de auto había pasó
una vez he ayudado a varias veces pero
una en particular es muy linda hay una
señora que estaba tratando de cambiar la
rueda de su auto y yo estaba con un
amigo mío de villa maría córdoba
paseando y estaba la señora el señor que
estaba dentro del auto no podía cambiar
la rueda del auto porque que era su
esposo porque tenía una capacidad
diferente
entonces la ayudamos a cambiar la rueda
resulta que al otro día vamos a la casa
de mi tía y cuando abro la puerta para
ir a tomar unos mates con mi tía que me
hace unas tortas riquísimas y resulta
que la señora estaba ahí y la señora le
contó lo que yo había hecho y la cara de
mi tía casi como la tuya y el acuerdo de
hoy me acuerdo y digo agua ok y esa cara
de xàtiva que adoro que falleció hace
unos días son regalos son retazos de la
vida y fíjate el detalle y bueno esos
son retazos que te regalan a alguien y
eso
de repente apareció justina cuando nació
el año y medio descubrimos que su
corazón estaba lastimado viví 12 años
con una vida prácticamente normal salvo
la medicación que tomaba y que hacía
muchos estudios cuando ya cumple cuando
ya tenía 12 años en el 2017 el 31 de
agosto de 2017 después de haber tenido
muchas descomposiciones hacemos una
análisis con su cardiólogo y descubrimos
que lamentablemente empezaba el proceso
de su trasplante iba trasplante durante
12 años algo habíamos escuchado el tema
yo soy donante de órganos mi papá que
falleció de un acb donamos sus órganos
mi mamá falleció de cáncer no pudimos
donar sus órganos pero la donante de
órganos y en ese momento
empezamos a preguntarnos yo siempre me
he preguntado por qué y para qué por eso
soy de la profesión que soy soy
innovador ego si si que ser innovador
bueno me hice de la tecnología tengo
equipos de drones trabajo con gente de
inteligencia artificial y tener las
cosas robóticas y con esos instrumentos
y esos recursos tratamos de hacer las
cosas de otra forma para que sean mejor
en diversos aspectos y comer marketing
salud etcétera
y bueno cuando empieza el proceso de
justina digo bueno y por qué porque
justina va a esperar un mes porque no
puede esperar una semana y las
respuestas que me iban dando me generaba
más preguntas
y el por qué es una pregunta que depende
cuando lo hagas la mayor parte de las
veces por lo menos para mí yo busco algo
concreto tangible o algo que me explique
el por qué está sucediendo pero la
pregunta de para qué es mucho más
profunda que también es otra pregunta
que siempre me hago
y en ese momento justina que yo vengo
del padre de innovación en el marketing
la comunicación se había convertido en
el proceso en el proyecto y el desafío
más importante de mi vida personal y
profesional porque una persona y
profesional al mismo tiempo no hay que
ser profesional y dos personas no somos
somos un todo integral
y en ese momento fuimos a justina con
algunas ideas que se nos habían ocurrido
y le empiezo a explicar lo que habíamos
estado analizando habíamos analizado
cómo habían sido las campañas de
conscientes de concientización porque
habíamos descubierto que faltaba
comunicar más el tema de la donación y
el trasplante de órganos y cuando yo le
estoy presentando la idea me dice papi
ayudemos a todo lo que podamos
ese es el para qué de todo esto para
ayudar a todo lo que podamos y hay un
tema con esto es el momento en el que
ella me lo dice porque no me lo dice a
esto jugando en casa con sus amigas
bailando y entro y yo le digo y ella me
dice sí y papel se motor que podemos no
me lo hice con 12 años sabiendo que si
el corazón no aparecía ella no seguía
con su vida y ella dijo ayudemos a todo
lo que podamos no dijo papi pedí por mi
corazón y eso el para que de eso
fue una energía poderosa que alimentó
todo el tiempo y alimenta todo el tiempo
el perro de la alegría el amor el hacer
y la valentía
antes yo tenía otras inspiraciones pero
en ese momento esa fue la implicación y
es la inspiración y además el corazón
que ven ahí es una manda la que ella
pintó y la pintó de muchos colores
ella es una nena alegre es una alegre
divertida que le gusta bailar que le
gusta cantar ella quería ser bailarina y
cantante y me dice leo justina qué lindo
corazón me sentí papá este es el corazón
que yo voy a recibir así lleno de
colores lleno de vida y bueno
pongámoslo en la puerta de la verdad de
la sala en ese momento ya estaba
internada la trinidad de palermo
y bueno que todo el mundo sepa que ese
es el corazón que estás esperando y que
lo esperas así con alegría
justina nena que era muy difícil verla
enojada y descubrirla
enojada entonces
eso nos inspiró a hacer la campaña
multiplicar por siete el 7 aparece
muchas veces en mi vida siete ciudades
siete colegios siete empresas dice la
religión cristiana que el siete es el
número de la perfección
por los siete sacramentos también es el
número del perdón siete veces siete
perdón siete veces siete
para nosotros en ese momento se
convirtió en que cada uno de nosotros
cuando nos vamos de esta vida porque
tenemos una fecha de vencimiento un día
de estos nos vamos a ir que mejor que
irnos de esta vida donando órganos y
dándole la oportunidad a siete personas
o hasta siete personas que se puedan
puedan continuar con su vida y mejorar
su calidad de vida y todo lo que hicimos
fue logrando se lograron
en tiempo récord hacer una ley que se
hizo en nueve meses la aprobarán 202
diputados capicúa agustina jugábamos yo
soy muy creyente de las señales ese es
otro motor en mi vida las señales el 202
capicúa de los 202 diputados que
aprobaron la ley que había sido
previamente aprobada con senadores con
putin jugamos a buscar patentes capicúas
cuando íbamos al colegio y nos
divertíamos muchísimo habéis ganado en
ya se ganaba yo y con mis hijos también
por eso hoy cuando lo llevo al colegio y
cuando aparecieron 202 de los diputados
dije guau hutín está acá con nosotros
jugando y divirtiéndose y contenta
porque sabe que esto va a dar más vida y
en agosto un mes después de vigencia de
la ley agosto 2018 se logran récords
mensuales en cantidad de donantes 88
donantes capicúa y 121 trasplantes
realizados capicúa yo cuchara baquetas
justina se está riendo con nosotros la
están pasando bien esté donde esté y
este como éste y entonces eso alimenta
constantemente el perro que yo quiero
que gane
en el otro perro no lo niego pero me
alimenta mucho más el paro que yo quiero
que gane y miren miren lo que pasó hoy
yo estaba ahí escuchando las personas
que estaban dando las charlas hay una
salita donde hay una mesa y bueno hay
una pizza creo que todavía está y
apareció ruperto si es roberto saben por
qué porque se llama así porque es el
pájaro con el que con justina jugábamos
cuando ella era chiquita yo hacía que el
pájaro aparecía en el patio y yo hablaba
y ruperto que le hablaba y jugado menos
divertíamos alguna vez debo reconocer
que agustín es una trampita de pájaro
para poder atraparlo que no lo atrapó y
era es ese pájaro es esa señal algunos
te puedes ir bueno dale si quiere es un
pájaro que una pieza apareció ahí se la
quería mover bueno puede ser puede ser
pero yo la señal que quiero tener de eso
es que justina me está diciendo para
peter es una charla ojalá
vos puedas transmitir lo que ellos te
transmitir que se inspiren que busquen
ese motor que los inspiren a lograr
cambios en la vida desde un detalle
chiquito a un detalle grande de los
detalles chiquitos se van acumulando y
pueden lograr algo enorme nosotros
cuando empezamos con la campaña
multiplícate por 7 no teníamos la más
idea de lo que estábamos haciendo y
lo que íbamos a lograr y nosotros
seguimos y hoy yo no puedo hacer subir
acá al club hindú vengan chicos cipriano
zeferino no puedo hacer subir a las
personas que conocí en las 7 ciudades
donde viví y a todas las personas que me
inspiran entonces elegí dos personas muy
especiales para mí que son ceferino
y cipriano
ellos son mi inspiración entre tantos
otros algo bueno va a pasar si hacen
algo no esperen que pasa algo bueno
sentado sin hacer nada y si el hacer
algo ojalá ojalá hecho esto les sirva
para inspirarse para encontrar la forma
de alimentar ese perro el perro que
queremos todos que gane que es el del
amor el de la alegría el de la esperanza
es de la valentía gracias a ustedes
[Aplausos]
[Música]